there is plenty of reaction online the
hashtags tier 4
uk lockdown and heathrow are among those
that have been trending
border closures and travel restrictions
resulted in chaotic scenes at london's
heathrow airport
one user shared this video of cues
outside one of the terminals
as more countries announced flight bans
here's what some passengers had to say
there's not a lot of people traveling
obviously it's kind of weird it's
actually a little bit easier to get in
and out but
the restrictions on travel is a lot
harder
it's tough to see family basically i
have been here
for last eight to seven years as a
visitor
and i'm confused
at this time basically when i arrived
here on 14th december
situation situation is totally different
it's hard time here it was a similar
picture at some pancreas railway station
in london
one user tweeting that in their opinion
eurostar social distancing was a joke
businesses that export seafood across
the continent are
sounding the alarm bells about the
impact of covid19
and brexit suggesting they may not
survive much longer
many people in the uk have been
criticizing prime minister boris
johnson's response to the pandemic
with some even questioning the new
strain by